[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a áfrica 7 días el
magazine informativo de france 24
dedicado al continente africano
comenzamos con los titulares a medida
que se acercan las elecciones
legislativas en senegal el clima
político es cada vez más tenso el
viernes 17 de junio violentas
manifestaciones tuvieron lugar en varias
ciudades del país tenemos informe la
república democrática del congo acusa a
wanda de violaciones territoriales y
crímenes de guerra abordamos el
deterioro de las relaciones entre ambos
países y al menos 86 personas fueron
asesinadas por yihadistas este es el
último balance de la masacre de éste
tenga en el noreste de burkina faso
neumáticos quemados contenedores en
llamas y gases lacrimógenos el pasado
viernes 17 de junio la capital
senegalesa dakar fue escenario de
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes y
agentes de la policía mientras el clima
político se tensa a un mes y medio de
las elecciones legislativas en el país
desde dakar nuestra corresponsal sara
sacó nos amplia
200 personas detenidas según el diario
oficial y 3 muertas es el duro balance
de las protestas del pasado viernes los
manifestantes exigían la validación de
una de sus listas de candidatos la lista
nacional de la gran coalición de
oposición no fue aceptada porque
presentaba un error pero precisamente en
esta lista anulada aparece es manson q
el líder de la oposición el viernes por
la noche el acusó al presidente maquinal
de querer eliminar a los opositores
políticos de toda competencia este
evento es solo el último episodio en el
enfrentamiento entre el poder y la
oposición y ahora a sólo unas semanas de
las elecciones el estancamiento político
parece total es una situación que
preocupa a los defensores de los
derechos humanos denuncian un retroceso
democrático esta situación se produce en
un momento en el que la inflación como
consecuencia de la guerra en ucrania
generando un enorme descontento y de
hecho durante las protestas muchos
ciudadanos salieron a la calle para
denunciar sus preocupaciones diarias
seguimos con el plan de deportación de
solicitantes de asilo del reino unido a
ruanda a pesar de la determinación del
gobierno británico de reubicar a sus
solicitantes de asilo a seis mil
kilómetros de su territorio para
disuadir las llegadas a través del canal
de la mancha el primer vuelo fue
cancelado tras una decisión de
emergencia del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos sin embargo el gobierno
británico aseguró que seguirá adelante
con sus planes escuchemos
estos repetidos obstáculos legales son
muy similares a los que enfrentamos con
todos los demás vuelos de deportación
pero creemos que estamos cumpliendo
plenamente nuestras obligaciones
nacionales e internacionales y los
preparativos para los próximos vuelos
que hagan comenzamos nuestra asociación
con ruanda no está amenazando
el perfil ser por su parte wanda ve el
acuerdo con londres como una solución a
un sistema de asilo global que falla
pero la oposición al gobierno ruandés
y de que se abandone el proyecto
argumentando que reino unido no debe
descargar sus obligaciones
internacionales en su país
seguimos en ruanda país al que la vecina
república democrática del congo acusa de
apoyar financiar y armar a los rebeldes
del movimiento m 23 en las últimas
semanas los insurgentes han multiplicado
sus ataques en el este de la república
democrática del congo pero el gobierno
ruandés niega rotundamente haberlos
apoyado detalles en el siguiente informe
los manifestantes que se ven en estas
imágenes se dirigen en la frontera con
ruanda en el este de la república
democrática del congo quieren ir al país
vecino al que acusan de apoyar al grupo
rebelde m23 responsable en las últimas
semanas de varios ataques en la zona
con bandas nos ataca desde hace 20 años
hoy pedimos la vigilancia de la
población hoy todos defendemos la causa
de la nación y apoyamos a nuestras
fuerzas armadas que luchan para poner al
enemigo fuera de combate por metro han
dotado en un mormón cuando intentaron
ingresar por la fuerza a ruanda los
manifestantes fueron dispersados por la
policía
pero las autoridades locales quisieron
mostrarle su comprensión
vamos a hacer todo lo posible para
expulsar a estos criminales a estos
terroristas esos partidarios del
territorio nacional a ruanda no le
gustamos no le tenemos miedo lucharemos
contra ella si quiere guerra tendrá
guerra
por el momento les agradecemos sus
acciones les pedimos que se manifiesten
pacíficamente
el mundo a manifesté así como el día
anterior en la capital hinchas a cientos
de personas se manifestaron también para
exigir la ruptura de relaciones
diplomáticas con ruanda y finalmente el
jueves 16 el gobierno congoleño alzó la
voz
wanda el consejo supremo de defensa ha
tomado las siguientes medidas 1 la
exigencia de que ruanda retire
inmediatamente sus tropas al amparo del
grupo terrorista m 23 del territorio
congoleño
la petición al gobierno de la república
muy réplica el congo que sorprende a
todos los protocolos de acuerdos
convenios y convenciones concluidos con
roban al bec lo wanda hay que retroceder
mucho en el tiempo para entender el
conflicto que se vive hoy en día la
colonización y la imposición de
fronteras por parte de los europeos
contribuyeron a las tensiones entre la
mayoría y la minoría tutsi en la región
este grupo armado estaba formado
mayoritariamente por tutsis y fue
derrotado en 2013 por kinshasa sin
embargo el m23 retomó las armas a
finales de 2021 culpando a las
autoridades congoleñas de no respetar un
acuerdo de desmovilización y
reintegración de sus combatientes
según la onu la violencia de los últimos
días ha obligado al menos 30.000
personas a huir de sus hogares
pasemos a burkina faso tras la masacre
ocurrida en la noche del 11 al 12 de
junio en la ciudad de se tenga en la que
más de 80 personas fueron asesinadas por
grupos armados tianguistas varios
supervivientes criticaron la inacción
del gobierno y denunciaron su desamparo
ante los atacantes
las fuerzas de seguridad hicieron
maletas y se fueron
supervivientes el atentado de say tenga
en el norte de burkina faso relatan que
se encontraron solos frente a los
atacantes los yihadistas que asesinaron
al menos a 86 personas la matanza tuvo
lugar en una zona que sufre regularmente
este tipo de ataques
es tan grave es tan grave y ni siquiera
podemos explicarlo ni siquiera puedo
expresar piense y tenga no quedan nadie
se quiere todas las casas lo mataron a
todos no distinguieron entre niños y
adultos y aunque nos atrincheramos en
las casas hacían todo lo posible por
abrir la puerta y matar a los niños ya
los hombres
como suele ocurrir en esta región el
atentado no ha sido reivindicado pero la
ciudad ya había sido atacada dos días
antes por los yihadistas que mataron a
11 gendarme
[Música]
hace poco hubo un ataque contra las
fuerzas de seguridad en la comuna de cei
tenga y murieron 11 personas algo que
lamentamos mucho pero el día siguiente
cuando vinieron a recuperar los cuerpos
las fuerzas de seguridad hicieron las
maletas y se fueron al día siguiente
vinieron hombres armados no
identificados para tomar posiciones
rodear el pueblo y disparar a todos los
que vieran
el ejercito burkinés había anunciado que
mató a unos cuarenta y hadise tas tras
el primer ataque según el gobierno los
yihadistas volvieron a se atenga para
vengarse el asalto a la ciudad es el
segundo más mortífero registrado en
burkina faso después del ataque de junio
de 2021 a la localidad de zhongjiang
donde según fuentes murieron 160
personas
el nuevo hombre fuerte del país el
coronel polarizada oh god ámbar que
derrotó al presidente electo rock mar
cristian kaboré a principios de enero
acusándolo de ser en eficaz frente a la
violencia yihadista había prometido
hacer de la seguridad su prioridad pero
tras este último atentado y sus escenas
de muertos los habitantes ya no ocultan
su decepción
dijeron que venían a luchar contra el
terrorismo allí les esperamos porque no
es una cuestión de confianza allí tienen
que estar a la altura tienen que
demostrarnos que tomaron las armas por
varias razones
desde 2015 los atentados atribuidos a
grupos yihadistas han dejado miles de
muertos y causado 2 millones de
desplazados en burkina
terminamos en senegal donde se ha
inaugurado la primera planta
desalinizadora de agua de mar un
proyecto concebido para combatir los
frecuentes cortes de agua que sufre en
la capital y su aglomeración pero la
iniciativa no entusiasma a los
ecologistas y los pescadores y los
comerciantes locales que están
preocupados por sus consecuencias
en esta playa de la capital senegalesa
dakar se está construyendo la primera
planta desalinizadora de aguas de mar
del país el presidente max al inauguró
este proyecto que pretende mejorar el
suministro de agua de la capital y su
aglomeración
grandes señoras y señores el proyecto
complejo y sin precedentes que lanzamos
hoy marcó un paso importante en la
materialización del plan senegal
emergente la razón la construcción de la
fábrica supone una inversión de más de
dos millones de dólares financiada por
un préstamo de la agencia internacional
japonesa pero para muchos el proyecto no
genera confianza los comerciantes de la
playa tendrán que irse para dar paso a
la estación de bombeo en la fábrica
hemos intentado alertar a la opinión
pública ya todos los interesados y hasta
ahora no se ha hecho nada así que
estamos obligados a cumplir la decisión
del estado estamos aquí a la espera del
siguiente paso a los pescadores y
ecologistas tampoco les convence el
proyecto los peces solían venir a
alimentarse cerca de las rocas pero
desde el inicio de las obras ya no vemos
ninguno además los buceadores ya no
pueden detectar los peces porque el agua
del mar se ha coloreado debido a los
residuos de la fábrica mientras tanto el
gobierno asegura que ha tomado todas las
medidas necesarias para limitar el
impacto en el medio ambiente la escasez
de agua afecta la vida de los habitantes
de dakar y con el crecimiento
demográfico este problema no hace más
que agravarse pero para los ecologistas
la desalinizadora no es la solución
especialmente para un país como senegal
que tiene agua en sus acuíferos
subterráneos está previsto que la planta
entre en funcionamiento en 2025
así cerramos esta edición de áfrica
siete días gracias por su sintonía nos
vemos la próxima semana
[Música]